ladies and gentlemen Academy Award
winner miss Angelica Houston
our second nominees for Best Picture has
inspired almost as much political
controversy as critical acclaim
Mississippi Burning stars two brilliant
actors Gene Hackman and Willem Dafoe as
FBI agents assigned to investigate the
1964 disappearance of three young civil
rights workers in Mississippi in this
scene the two confront each other over
tactics and a few other matters besides
during a vigil at the hospital bed of
one of their witnesses Best Supporting
Actress nominee Frances McDormand
Mississippi burnings two extraordinary
stars Gene Hackman and Willem Dafoe
would you like to explain about your
hair it's for uh film I'm making right
now called triumph of the Spirit I came
here from Auschwitz in Poland where
we're in the middle of production right
now we're gonna present the Oscar for
art direction that occurred to me it's
kind of a confusing term so let me
clarify it an art director does for
movies what an interior decorator and a
landscape architect combined do for your
home only the art director does it on
time and it doesn't cost as much here
are the nominees for Beach's art
direction by Albert Grenier set
decoration by Garrett Lewis
or Dangerous Liaisons art direction by
Stuart Craig set decoration by Jared
Gerrard James for Rain Man art direction
by Ida random set decoration decoration
by Linda de Sena for Tucker the man in
his dream art direction by ginta Belarus
set decoration by Armin Gans
for Who Framed Roger Rabbit art
direction by Elliot Scott set decoration
by Peter Howard's and the Oscar goes to
Dangerous Liaisons Stuart Franken Jane
I just like to acknowledge some terrific
work from my fellow nominees I'm very
honored to receive this thank you very
much